Hey it's Joey and welcome to Better Ideas.
Now a lot of people in this highly digital
social media-driven society are finding it
increasingly difficult to get work done without
getting distracted by the social media.
I've experienced the same problem whether
it's endlessly scrolling through the newsfeed
on Facebook, hitting that discover tab on
Instagram - just constantly refreshing it,
or just binge-watching YouTube videos.
But I've been fortunate enough to stumble
upon four awesome tips that have really helped
me increase my productivity, decrease the
amount of time I waste on the internet and
social media in general - all without compromising
my ability to be reached by other people.
Number one: install the News Feed Erradicator
Chrome extension.
News Feed Eradicator is a free extension that
blocks your Facebook News Feed and replaces
it with a motivational quote.
You can still access messenger and view notifications,
but it stops you from endlessly scrolling
which is the main problem we're trying to
avoid here.
This is definitely one of the best and most
easily implemented strategies to help you
stop mindlessly scrolling through the Facebook
news feed.
Number Two is delete the Facebook app off
your phone and replace it with the Messenger
app.
This is helpful for the exact same reason
that my first tip was helpful - it keeps you
away from the News Feed.
The News Feed is bad news.
Why do you need to know what meme Johny Smith
tagged Suzie Q in two hours ago?
It's useless.
It's crap!
Stop wasting time on useless unsubstantial
things and start getting good, meaningful
work done.
Number four is install the Forest app on your
phone.
There are a million videos explaining what
the Forest app is and it has millions of downloads,
basically, I'll just put the link in the description
and you can check that out.
My fourth and final tip is possibly the most
practical and the most important: Don't use
social media first thing in the morning.
Try having a one hour period in the morning
where you don't check social media, don't
look at the internet - and just dedicate it
to starting the day off right.
Maybe eat a good breakfast, take a shower,
get dressed into something fly, and then make
a to-do list for the day or read a book.
Starting the day off right by doing something
productive will set the tone for the entire
rest of the day.
Studies have shown that willpower is a finite
resource that depletes throughout the day
the more decisions you make.
Which means that in the morning, when you
haven't made any decisions at all, make the
right decision - to do work - and use that
tremendous amount of willpower you have to
get important things done.
If you follow these four tips, you have my
personal guarantee that social media and the
internet will start becoming less of a problem
in your life and you'll get a lot more work
done.
If you like this video and want to see me
make more be sure to hit that subscribe button
down below if you haven't already.
Like the video if you liked it and comment
if you didn't.
Or comment if you did.
It doesn't really matter.
Just leave something in the comments because
I love looking at comments and I respond to
ALLOFTHEM.
Catch you in the next video.